not yet not yet we do have Andrew with
us Andrew congratulations throughout to
a great start for uh you told us a bit
about the opening phase and I want to
emphasize this position because it was
quite crazy it felt at least visually
that you're completely breaking through
right but it's not that easy after this
H4 Rook G8 what are you thinking about
taking it like this
yeah actually so
um when you play this G5 F6 right here I
mean I saw it was a legal move but I I
thought there's no way this could work
but then the more I looked at it it was
a complete mess it was so hard to judge
and um I actually missed that after H4
Rook G8 um Rook G8 is a really strong
move yes this move I missed because and
it's not clear what to do if I play
Queen H6 king of seven
um the threat is Rook HJ here so even my
take on G5 Rook h8 should be good for
black yeah exactly really bad
yeah so yeah King F7 I should play Queen
H5 check
um yeah it's a question of assessment
right yeah
I couldn't see clearly what to do for
white um this huge mess there's so much
going on but I decided to choose Queen
D3 and I think that was the right
decision and
you were trying to open up the position
trying to get to his King he was trying
to get your king complete mess yeah I
was a complete mess um I think after the
critical moment was after CD 265 you're
supposed to take edn position is
extremely complex I I didn't see it and
because Queen A8 looks scary but after
King G7 Knight H5 King h8 there's
nothing here so
um after Ed I was just planning on
playing Knights 2 and we have very very
complicated position
um
all three results possible but after GF
almost impossible to assess it yeah just
Bishop D7 yeah such a random placement
for all the PCS more or less right but
after GF DC I'm not sure what he missed
because this looks not great for black
takes and there's the smooth Queen B6
was very key
um perhaps this is what he missed this
might have been what he missed because
his King is um getting cooked in the
open and yeah the idea is Queen C7
Knight F4 yeah and I actually think he
had uh the best defense was Bishop E4
here I think
takes Quincy for this key he's supposed
to play King E5 here that's right and
here I was calculating a lot it's
actually a lot harder than thinking
about F4 I can't click here Bishop D2
Bishop D2 some dual threats of f4 bishop
and then Bishop B4 also have rookie four
rookie one which wins and I the move I
calculate for black Heroes Rook G4 okay
looks like it might hold on but then I
wasn't that clear to me I didn't have
much time but I thought here Queen C6
might win
what is this type of Chess yeah no I
didn't see Bishop H4 but oh my goodness
but but I figured I figured
I figured you actually went for King E5
there I should find a win there somehow
but um yeah King D7 was a nice little
trap obviously the idea is a rookie for
Queen F2 and tables are turned Yes again
but uh unfortunately I have Bishop F4
which I think wins clearly on the spot
yeah Rook D1 and his King is just
toasted yeah yeah Andrew congratulations
uh good start for you guys join the
conversation any questions for our
current leader uh first of all that was
a really thrilling game was there any
moment there Andrew that you felt like I
may have missed something or did you
feel so confident throughout
um
after C takes D5 I was expecting Ed as I
said but after gf3
I hadn't I was a little bit afraid I was
missing something but I really couldn't
see what he wanted
um so I just had to trust my calculation
there's there's a lot to calculate but
um right it seems to all work for white
so uh you know my sort of thinking was
I'll just play you know what I think and
then we'll see what he does and then
we'll just go from there move it move by
move a thrilling Victory congratulations
thank you uh and Andrew I have one more
question I feel like Jason he plays
really fast in the opening very worried
about his preparation or did you just
think F6 is really bad and you're gonna
do great there
yeah actually so he played this C5 line
which I believe he doesn't usually play
um assumed he I assumed he had some
preparation here so I I chose a slightly
different line
um from what I usually play and he was
still playing quickly um but I think
generally he was already out of the book
but he he maybe the type of player he
just plays fast or maybe in this certain
game he wanted to you know put pressure
on the clock but I'm pretty sure he was
out of book um just playing quickly
though and it really wasn't easy to um
and they'll find the right way for white
yeah great game congratulations
absolutely absolutely yeah